hey guys Peter Rubin senior editor at
Wired here with the stars of what is for
my money the best sketch show on
television keegan-michael key
Jordan Peele of Key & Peele season 3 is
coming September 18th on Comedy Central
so you guys have worked together for
years now not MADtv broke out and are
doing your own thing what can we expect
in season 3 there's carryover what
what's for fans of the show who's coming
back it's funny that you say carryover
yeah um we're you're gonna see the
president Luther again they're gonna
make an appearance it's not every
character that people have told us they
want back we're bringing back don't you
- yeah donkey teeth will be back you
will see it you will see don't you in
some capacity
excellent you will see him yes I was
gonna ask what have you guys done
comic-con before this is our first time
start so how's it been kind of coming to
the the mecca of that it's it's been
it's like delightfully overwhelming it
yeah it would totally be here as
complete fanboy yeah
but we're coming in here with a show so
it's we kind of we can't completely just
we can't just get out and go out you
know go out on the floor I think without
some sort of mask or something all right
what are your kind of individual strong
suits in in geek world the geek world uh
well I'm the video gamer I am I mean we
share a lot of things we have huge we
love Game of Thrones both Game of
Thrones Game of Thrones guys aliens we
talk about aliens a lot yeah we just saw
the cool what we thought was the coolest
costume in Jordans but spitting the last
20 minutes trying to beat this costume
and I think he's already done it but I
just saw a red shirt like an original
Star Trek red shirt with a face hugger
with an alien space race straight mashup
and then a little sign on his chest that
said free hugs pretty badass that
perfect there's a couple at you though
and frankly I am certainly in a position
to greenlight things over on blade in an
orange prison jumpsuit you had me a
blade Lando Calrissian half-burnt like
to face your deep cut is talking
straight up
Harvey Dent pre-burn original Batman
movie the artist formerly known as
Prince that's nice that's nice
oh what a pin on what the other one hit
him with the cam peel 100 we were
talking about a Jar Jar in a tux and
blackface right top it's double black
faces yes so season three you have kind
of expanded the scope by bringing in
people who are actually in other genre
shows yes mm-hmm who were some of these
cameos against oh well David being cool
he was the star of Grimm right is is
actually he is the we're doing a zombie
sketch or Jordan both playing guys who
are extras in some kind of Walking Dead
type show and David is the star of that
show so that so there's a little kind of
like you know us doing our character
thing in a zombie genre with another guy
from a fairy tale genre it's like yeah
it's mash up central so the thing that
sets the show apart just to stand out
for a little bit is that the the
production values the work that goes
into making it look good is just out of
control
there's the script and then there's
making it look like you spend millions
and millions of dollars on it how do you
make that happen I mean where's that I
mean from the beginning we were just you
know we were obsessed with this idea of
doing John Rose right of just jumping
off from just it done as well as
possible and then you know occasionally
we'll have a scene that's a gritty and
it'll it's dramatic and kind of scary
and then we'll have the most ridiculous
script underneath and that juxtaposition
we love we shot on the universal back
lot we come to work like the cranes and
joists and Jerian it's like wow Isis
come up I mean look you so you feel
every day that you're showing up on a
movie set right which makes you feel for
me makes me feel like an actor more than
I'm not a comic right right we're actors
trying to create this world and then the
humor allows itself to exist in the
context of the world for each of you is
there one that you go back to like you
know this was really the pin
we this for me was the sublime Platonic
ideal of I I mean I'm not I don't I'm
speak for both of us but I feel like
there's something so special to me about
the first pizza order scene that's me
that's me and there's something about
the acting in it the humor is clear and
subtle at exactly the same time and it's
just it's it's a perfect amalgam of
everything we want gay people to be just
it's interesting too because that's one
of the few things sketches where we were
and you know we did we shot them on
separate we work together our two are
two parts you know I shot my bit first
and then he shot his but that one came
together I'm a huge fan of you know we
came out of the gate with that
scene that to me is kind of it is uh
it's I think it's just perfectly puts
into uh puts our voice in in a scenes
yeah as far as kind of showing the
comedy more than you telling the comedy
or explaining it you know there's those
different layers in there like a big
club sandwich no dagwood special yeah I
respect both your opinion but the
correct answer is actually Liam Neeson
Peter Reuben for wired Keep Watch we've
got more comic-con videos on the way
you